they do have stuff to hide and i don't
think they realize that they have stuff
to hide and now they've just made it
really obvious to everyone who knows
what to look for good molecules is a
brand with a pretty unique marketing
strategy they show all their ingredients
lists they say they have nothing to hide
and it even shows the percentages of
every single ingredient good molecules
claims that this is a whole new level of
transparency and they hope that others
in the industry will do the same
but is that really transparent hi i'm
michelle of lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd and cosmetic chemist and
today we're going to do a deep dive into
good molecules claims so on the face of
it this definitely looks sciencey you
have lots of numbers they go from
biggest to smallest some of these
products even have two decimal places
which gives you
at least four units of scienceness but i
think there are some really big issues
with this that might not be immediately
obvious first off you can't tell
everything from an ingredients list a
standard ingredients list gives you all
of the ingredients in descending order
from the heaviest to the lightest and
then once you go below one percent they
can be in any order one of the big
issues with this is that you don't know
the exact percentage you can only really
guess at the one percent line but even
if you know the exact percentages there
are other issues too first off there's
the quality of the ingredient a lot of
ingredients have a range of different
qualities even if they have the same
name on an ingredients list natural
ingredients like oils and plant extracts
will be affected by lots of different
factors like where you get them from the
exact farm the country the time of year
in a lot of products there are important
impurities that will be different for
example in niacinamide you can get
niacin as an impurity and this will
actually make your skin flush a lot of
the time when people find that their
skin flashes from niacinamide it is
because of the impurities and so better
brands might look for something that has
less of the niacin there are also
blender materials where there's multiple
things under the one ingredient name for
example saterial alcohol is a mix of
settle and sterile alcohol and you don't
know how much there is of each one they
can be in different ratios the list
itself can also be inaccurate even if
everyone has tried really hard to make
sure it's accurate the cosmetic chemist
has to calculate the ingredients list
and sometimes an ingredient supplier
will give you a percentage range for
example they might say this saterial
alcohol has 45 to 55 settle alcohol so
the usual practice is to just take the
midpoint pretend it's 50 and calculate
it from that so the list isn't as
precise as you might believe there's
also the issue of stability even if you
put in a particular ingredient at a
particular percentage at the very start
of the process that might not be what
you have in the product by the end
ingredients like retinol are pretty
unstable and so by the time it arrives
on your door the one percent might be
maybe a fifth of that some names are
also used for multiple ingredients for
example dimethicone is a polymer that
comes in lots of different lengths and
the length tells you what the properties
are so you can get really short polymers
of dimethicone and they'll be really
runny and light you can get really long
polymers and they'll be a lot thicker
and stickier and the word dimethicone is
used for both of these and everything in
between this also happens for cardboard
which describes a whole bunch of
different polymers that are used for
thickening also plant extracts a lot of
extracts can be extracted with different
solvents and that changes what is
actually in the extract in terms of
chemicals it's also really difficult to
tell if there's some sort of special
delivery system in the product for
example you can encapsulate particular
ingredients and that changes how well
they work for example you can have a
lower percentage of encapsulated
regional and that can work just as well
as a higher percentage of unencapsulated
retinol so this ingredient list doesn't
have any transparency with that because
they are just using the standard
ingredient names you would find on any
other ingredient list the other issue is
that this gives you a whole bunch of
really useless info that no one really
needs i think this actually makes it
less transparent because now it's a lot
more confusing you have a whole bunch of
distractions and you can't just zero
into the stuff you actually want to know
you do get the percentages of every
active ingredient which i think is
useful even though there are differences
in potency and quality and that sort of
thing i still like to know roughly what
i'm expecting but now we also have all
the percentages of the inactive
ingredients which is like who cares this
tells me there's 83 water but if i had a
different product that had 87 water
that's not going to help me make a
decision i have propane dial at two
percent i would probably still buy it if
it's at five percent carbama is at 0.06
carbohydrate changes the texture of the
product but you could also work this out
by just putting it on your hand or
reading a review it would be way more
useful to read a review and find out how
tacky it is whether it feels drying or
sticky or thick or if it's difficult to
apply or even just watching a video of
someone applying it on their face or in
the back of their hand as a cosmetic
chemist if i wanted to copy this formula
it would give me an easier starting
point but it still isn't that useful
because there are so many different
ingredients that are listed under the
one ingredient name so carb member for
example this has 0.06 carbama i don't
know which one it is out of the hundreds
of different carpenters which would give
me hundreds of different textures i
would still have to make it based on my
best guess and then check the texture
and then adjust it until i got it to
match this product so even for this
reverse engineering purpose this still
isn't that useful i do like the active
ingredient percentages but lots of
brands already tell us this so this
isn't really bringing that much radical
transparency to the table i guess i
would like it if more brands did list
their active ingredient percentages with
maybe some disclaimers about potency so
for example if they have a particularly
potent version of an ingredient it would
be nice to know the equivalent
percentage it would be for a planar
product i realized that a lot of brands
don't like to do this because it is a
bit more difficult to explain but it
would be nice if that information was
maybe hidden away somewhere on their
website and the nerdier people could
still find it interestingly the active
ingredient percentages are kind of
revealing here and i think it kind of
shows that good molecules doesn't really
know what they're doing in terms of this
transparency claim so first off the
niacinamide brightening toner this tells
us we have 0.1 3o ethyl ascorbic acid if
you want brightening you generally need
more than one percent 3of ascorbic acid
which is 10 times this amount the reason
you would put 0.1 into a product is to
make the ingredient list look nicer or
as an antioxidant to protect the product
but it won't have these skin brightening
benefits so here's a cosmetic chemist
secret if you put in a really tiny
amount of an ingredient you can still
say contains vitamin c and then let
consumers just make assumptions but it's
considered unethical to say it contains
vitamin c for brightening because you
don't have enough in there it doesn't
match the percentages used in studies
but a lot of companies don't have people
who understand what claims they should
be able to make based on the evidence
writing their actual claims in this case
their claim is formulated with
niacinamide vitamin c arbutin and
licorice root extract to brighten and
improve appearance of enlarged pores
but vitamin c isn't actually doing any
of this brightening and improving
appearance of pores in this particular
product the licorice root extract which
is also part of their brightening claim
that's also at point one percent and
again i don't think that percentage is
going to do much there is a lot of
natural variation with plant extracts
but i've never seen one this potent they
also say they increased it from their
old formula i'm not sure why they
increased it to 0.1 percent maybe it is
super potent but
this doesn't tell me that and it would
be more transparent if they told me they
had a super potent licorice root extract
this is the announcement they made on
instagram when they first started doing
these nothing to hide ingredient lists
the world has enough skincare that
doesn't work that's a result of adding
fairy dust to products instead of an
effective level of actives or key
ingredients the fact they said this
right as they were showing the world
they had these very dust amounts of
vitamin c and probably licorice extract
kind of says to me that they don't
really know what they're doing they're
sort of telling on themselves if they
were actually trying to be transparent
and they knew what they were doing they
wouldn't be making claims that they
can't support
or they would tell you they have very
dust amounts of 3-0 ethyl ascorbic acid
and plant extracts there are other
examples of this so the cleansing gel
has 0.1 pineapple extract which probably
isn't enough to be exfoliating the
glycolic toner has 0.1 aloe extract
which is meant to be soothing the bha
clarified serum has 0.1 grapeseed oil
and pomegranate oil and those are meant
to be hydrating maybe they do have super
potent super fancy plant extracts and it
would be really nice and transparent if
they could tell us about them there are
also some calculation errors which i
think is a little bit petty of me to
point out but if they were going to show
everything then maybe they should have
had it right their overnight exfoliating
treatment says it has 10 alpha and beta
hydroxy acids and it lists them but if
you add them together you don't get 10
there's also another 0.1 fairy dust
issue here point my percent salicylic
acid is not enough to make a claim for
acne and sun damage plus acne is a drug
claim and this is not a drug this one is
probably super petty and i'm not sure if
anyone else has discovered it because
they probably weren't just nitpicking as
hard as me but the percentages on the
bha clarify serum don't add up to 100
they add up to 100.4 and there are 16
ingredients on here at 0.4 percent or
under so this seems like a pretty big
error also some products don't have
their percentages listed so saying that
they have nothing to hide by showing
this sorta says they have something to
hide with the other products there are
so many other things they could do to be
more transparent they could show us the
clinical results or maybe they could say
that they don't have them because they
didn't want to pay for them because it's
a lot cheaper to just print out the
ingredient list for marketing in one of
their instagram posts they also say it
also makes it easy to see which
ingredients we left out this includes
polysorbate 20 fragrance drying alcohol
and a long list of others it would be a
lot more transparent to not have clean
beauty fear-mongering maybe they could
tell people that parabens and sulfates
are fine also their niacinamide serum
has polysorbate 60 which is not that
different from polysorbate 20. other
people have also mentioned that their
sponsored posts especially those from
dermatologists have hidden disclosures
so
maybe that might be something to fix if
they're going to be more transparent
they also have a lot of drug claims on
their products so for example they say
rosehip oil will regenerate and heal
skin which is a very strong claim and it
also goes beyond the evidence we have
for what rosehip oil does to skin they
also say we hope this new level of
transparency invites feedback when we
can improve why not hire someone maybe a
cosmetic chemist to check their claims
instead of waiting for free feedback
which i do realize i have just given
them maybe i should be writing them an
invoice if they pay me i will let you
know in the interest of transparency i
rate this marketing strategy a hot mess
they do have stuff to hide and i don't
think they realize that they have stuff
to hide and now they've just made it
really obvious to everyone who knows
what to look for i believe this is
called showing your ass so let me know
what you think and let me know what
other dodgy marketing claims i should
look at next if you like this video like
and subscribe and click the notification
bell you can follow me on instagram and
tick tock and check out my blog good
molecules let me know who to send the
invoice to